I'll crack it
[Music]
hey guys I'm Gregory and I'm Renee area
Renee area is on Instagram Twitter and
YouTube she's also one of the hosts of
an afterbuzz TV segment I'm not many
days on many segments she's the star of
after but I no one else is important on
that show well Renee friend of mine and
mainly amber plasters friend I would
just like okay we'll collab fine if you
really want to come on this channel so
bad or a now you to come on her name
there's a chap called record rack up
this is one of the best channels ever
they tend to do these sketches that are
very violent and weird I don't know what
this one's going to be they have this
Ronald McDonald character yeah his very
violent twisted perverted is like the
total antithesis of what we've come to
hand synthesis I've never used that word
I impress myself so like that you know
Nicole
Renee is watching her right if there's
something confused on that you're it's
your prompt and I'm watching rag a
racket before Ronald Rose big youtubers
featuring Logan Paul
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay Brene that was possibly one of the
weirdest introductions I could have
given you to this channel whose videos
are not normally that I can't even
fathom what they usually are they're
usually very violent and disturbing but
that's part of what makes them funny I
was honestly one of the worst I didn't
even know I don't even know my facebook
like the whole time because I just
remember my mouth withdraw all of the
thing but the whole time without drawing
that face paint look I'm like oh my gosh
like to give it off yeah the Ron
McDonald characters one though like they
have this meet the McDonald's McDonald's
and like it's like it's like a
disturbing horror movie there the story
of them I like what how this video
started off though talking about how
their views have been going down yeah
because everyone knows that YouTube's
algorithm is the greatest thing to have
ever happen to YouTube it is totally not
made me worry about my channel at all
everything has been up Adia so then yeah
that's like they youtube they censor
things now right you can have it you're
talking about the restricted mode oh
yeah they just added that right yeah the
algorithm now the restricted mode you
can just keeps getting better and better
yes little concern no it's not
Rene Howard please don't pick this video
yeah don't restrict this video if it's
going after you know because I thought
about that too how people will create
like you know cause beef with other
youtubers in order to get their views up
yeah I think it works
I'm totally worth it yeah these people
are gonna totally find out whoever likea
really tweeted to and stuff yeah look
Logan polish up and it was fun rice gum
I don't know that is I don't know dad I
don't know more youtubers to film
onboarding I know Logan I actually do
know him because I saw him he's on one
of the YouTube bread series I have seen
him before
do you find him physically attractive
he's an attractive guy would you date
Logan Paul probably not why not because
I'm not single maybe if I was single and
he was a decent guy and he didn't do
that in real life well he did a video
like you know maybe maybe we'd like grab
coffee or ice cream or pizza I'm kind of
hungry I'm gonna move on now that's a
good idea I just thought I'd have a
little awkward moment there for
president that was more than enough for
like moment I think those were awkward
moments like that like a few I think
moment will be like good we're talking
about the video what's going on with us
much attack what just happened oh really
we're in creepy oh yeah oh yeah yeah
let's moved on man of the program I
never thought a video would leave me
speechless but why is that left you so
speechless it wasn't that disturbing was
it I'm just confused what I watched you
watch the ultimate diss track that's
what you just watched I think it's time
we consult other youtubers - it's a hell
join in on the fun yeah yeah bring
others down what are sir youtubers you
know Trisha Paytas no idea who that is
boom insult to you you're nothing to me
you're nothing to grab your nothing on
no one well there's another reactor out
there who I constantly go after so I
have to go after him again you know he's
ugly fat black man named Tyrone Magnus
and he does reactions he has almost a
million followers like good for you
people only subscribers they feel sorry
for her
fat-ass is now you super buff and that's
why everyone likes them oh is channel
afterbuzz TV as I said you've heard of
that I don't know worst personalities
I've ever seen oh they're okay there's
like this Persian chick and his
redheaded weirdo oh the red has like a
super freak okay like um amber disaster
macam burp laughter like the wall oh god
yeah oh and they're two very
unattractive people that's I think a
worldwide acclaim like what can you do
nothing wait on them in another video
yeah definitely don't follow them at all
however it's an it's an image I never
say this is in a person
no not only behind about only the other
back yeah like secretly put it on the
internet for everyone to see but I won't
tell the Persian chick whatever what
rhymes with Renee tane Bonet
hello like how you had like several
names ready to go to Buster run
all right this video is awkward and done
hey subscribe to the real rejects
subscribe to raka raka yes dog Rene
Arielle is swell you can go check her
out on Instagram oh damn on Twitter with
her and she also is on YouTube you dude
go there was no as we I was with you
just really knew you knew boom kind of
how do I incorporate boob into YouTube
because it's a 1x1 Rhimes the most go
check out her boobs on youtubes nah I
could work your boyfriend's I going to
watch this right
I'm threatened